a psychologist walked into a room while
teaching Stress Management to an
audience as she raised a glass of water
everyone expected that they'd be asked
is this glass half empty or half full
but instead with a smile on her face she
asked how heavy do you think this glass
of water is people called out eight
ounces 16 ounces 20 ounces and she
replied the weight of this glass doesn't
matter it all depends on how long I hold
it if I hold it for just a minute it's
not a problem the glass still feels
light but if I hold it for an entire day
my arm would start to feel numb and
paralyzed the glass would feel
unbearable the weight of the glass never
changes but the longer I hold it the
heavier it becomes see the stresses and
worries in life are like a glass of
water if you think about them for just a
while nothing happens if you think about
them for a bit longer they begin to hurt
and if you think about them all day long
then you will feel paralyzed incapable
of doing anything so remember to put the
glass down Jimmy Harmon